[Applaudissements]
rires
[Musique]
où
il avait juré fidélité un état mais même
idéalisé des objets de 15 et c'était la
seule date analysé
elle voulait devenir je n'allais pas
bien ces traitements
mais nous intégrer sow venu à fédérer
narbonnais vêtements tu as pris la bad
en gros tu as préféré mettre les voiles
n'a plus donné de luz au loto a tourné
la page sur un drame une fleur de la
médaille
désolé mais quand tu joues tu sais
qu'elle est mariée
patron
tu reviendras car maintenant on est à
oublier
[Musique]
désolé
eh oui
non
[Musique]
5h10 n'y a plus accès n'était pas là
pour l'assister
est entendu là et c'est un triste et tu
repenses aille à son joueur tout des
vêtements
en étant brisé son coeur ou alors
qu'elle fait mutuellement
loin de moi on est loin de l'époque où
elle joue une vitre on doit mettre en
scène
comme hitler mais tu n'as plus de
blizzard
surtout maintenant que tu t'en vas y toi
quand tu joues tu sais qu'elle est
mariée
[Musique]
tout y est
oui
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la nomme gangwal en plomb